Today we're gonna talk about how AWS
channel partners and their end customers
can transform their business and deliver
more joint success
using new AWS service called Billing
Transfer.
Billing transfer introduces a new era
for AWS channel partner billing
and governance.
There are 3 key benefits that we'll cover
today. First,
channel partners and their end customers now
will have enhanced security
autonomy.
End customers of channel partners can now
operate in an entirely separate
organization from their reseller. This
allows both of these two entities
to self-control their own AWS
organization. Second,
billing transfer will simplify
billing operations for channel partners
because partners shared organizations
with their end customers before using billing
transfer.
Partners had to proliferate their
organizations and manage billing across hundreds
of organizations. You can now consolidate
billing in a single organization
across all end customers.
Lastly,
using billing transfer, partners can now
protect their proprietary discounts
and rates
away from their end customers. The bills
and chargeable billing artifacts are delivered
exclusively
to the partner in their own organization,
while customers
maintain self governance in their in
a separate organization.
Before we dive into the problems that
resulted in the need
for billing transfer, we have to understand
the existing AWS account
construct.
Within AWS organizations there are
two types of accounts.
There's a management account and a member
account.
The management account today
has full administrative control over
the organization. It can establish things
like service control policies. It
manages multi-account governance settings
like guard duty,
control tower, landing zones,
but that same account is responsible
for billing in the entire organization.
This means that for channel partners to manage
billing for end customers, they traditionally
had to control this management account
while end customers operated within the member
accounts.
What this resulted in
is various conflicts over
that administrative access control
in the management account.
Channel partners and end customers had to compromise
over partner control of the management account
in order for them to have
billing access,
while end customers then delegate away
all of their governance controls as well
and creates a security risk for many end
customers working under channel partners.
It also results in operational
inefficiencies where partners
now have to create dozens or hundreds
of organizations, retrieve billing
artifacts at the end of every month from those
organizations, and make payments there
just to manage their multi-account,
uh, reselling business.
And lastly, together these create scalability
challenges for partners. It's harder
to close deals because you have to convince
every end customer
why the channel partner needs to control route
to the management account,
and it's harder to manage your customer base
because the channel partners have to go into
all of these separate accounts
to manage billing and configure management
account level settings for their end customers.
That's why we're excited to introduce
billing transfer, which is now generally
available through AWS billing and
cost management
today.
Billing transfer allows the management
account of one organization
to delegate its billing to a separate
AWS organization.
This allows channel partners and end customers
to now operate in separate organizations
while the partner exclusively manages
billing and the end customer does not
have to compromise on control of
their own organization.
Billing transfer gives partners a
few key benefits. First, centralized
management,
which allows you to manage multiple
end customers from a single partner account
which will receive bills.
It allows you to have privacy of your margins
without sac without asking
end customers to sacrifice control of
their own management accounts as those
chargeable artifacts are delivered exclusively
to the partner.
And together it gives you operational efficiency
where you no longer have to manage hundreds of accounts
for customers.
For end customers, they now can have
complete environment control. There's
no more
trade-off when onboarding to a reseller
through the channel programs.
They also for the first time have
cost visibility through native AWS
cost management tooling.
This means your end customers can now also
use Cost Explorer cost and usage
reports and soon will also be able to
use cost anomaly detection RISP
reports within their own separate
organization while procuring through the channel partner.
Together these make those sales
conversations easier.
We're making it an even playing field
for partners to compete to,
uh, deliver services to end
customers.
So how does this work in the billing
and cost management
experience?
You can see now the partner and customer
are in two separate organizations. It's
no longer a shared organization where member
accounts are separated to customers.
Within the customer organization, they
will not receive any invoices or
bills from AWS.
They will be able to view costs at the rates
that are determined by the solution provider.
So using AWS billing conductor, solution
providers will be able to show custom rates
to that end customer or public pricing rates.
The partner will receive chargeable
AWS invoices with the
actual price they pay,
and they can view chargeable or pro
forma costs.
So that means the partner can actually view
the cost explorer experience
that the end customer has in their management
account. This allows you to toggle
between those two,
and you'll do that
through AWS Cost Explorer.
Billing transfer also allows you to
centralize billing delivery to a
single management account
across multiple customers.
So in this example,
the partner here would receive 4 invoices,
one for the consumption within each of your
customers
and one for the partner's own consumption in
their internal organization.
This allows you to maintain segregation
of those bills,
use your existing integrations with,
uh, third party billing tools to
determine the re-rating to your end customers,
all while customers maintain their separate
organizations.
Billing transfer is available
through the billing and cost management
uh console in AWS.
Within the billing cost management console, you can
send invitations to invite end
customers to transfer their billing
to you. You can also centralize
manage your centralized invoice delivery
and payments.
You can switch between the views your end
customer has and the views the partner
has of their chargeable rates, and you can
set custom pricing to show to your end customers.
Along with this, we've also launched
an entirely new AWS Partner
Central experience.
So in AWS Partner Central,
we've made it easier for you to now
qualify for channel benefits and
channel discounts on your end customers'
consumption.
You can manage all of your accounts that
you use
against your channel programs in
one place.
You can self-activate these accounts.
No more waiting for any manual approvals
from AWS,
and you can establish relationships
with customers once per
organization. You no longer have to complete
end user reporting on every single customer
account.
Tell us who the customer is once at their management
account level, and that will be inherited by
all of the member accounts in the
organization. This new partner central
experience is also
fully enabled by public
APIs that you can integrate with
to report on your channel ecosystem
and customer base from your own
CRM or first party tooling.
There are also new APIs in billing and
cost management that will allow you
to automate the
billing operations and onboarding of
end customers
through billing transfer.
Let's hear from our partners what some of the benefits
of this new experience are.
There's 3 key areas that I wanna hit.
First, you can now grow
faster by offering your end customers
control.
End customers never want to
make any trade-offs in their AWS
experience based on their procurement channel.
I think that we, we all know is true.
You can now leave your root access
to the customer. Let them retain their
own organizational control and
self-governance
while you still manage their billing and
deliver value-added services as a
reseller. It simplifies your
pre-sales and sales conversations,
and makes it easier for you to close deals.
Second, it simplifies your billing and
sales operations.
You're now receiving all of those bills
in a single
AWS account.
You're able to rerate to the customer
within AWS billing conductor.
And you no longer have to rely
on manual processes to
report accounts to the channel
programs in order to get channel
discounts applied. You can do all of that
to automate your FinOs workflows,
rebuild natively, and simplify
your third party tooling stack.
Together these should help partners scale
more profitably with AWS.
You can now simplify the workflows
and conversations with your end customers
to grow faster and reduce the
operational costs you have to put in in
order to deliver services to every
single customer account.
We wanna thank all of our launch partners
that helped us in this launch.
Um, we had an extensive beta
and took a lot of feedback from partners who are
experts in channel programs,
um, to get us here.
Um, so thank you to all of these partners
Software One, SHI,
TD CINex, Reddington, and Commit.
As we wrap up, let me emphasize
what makes billing transfer transformational.
For partners you can now scale more
efficiently and grow faster.
You can simplify sales
conversations and open new opportunities
that were previously closed because of the
channel program's root access
requirements.
Second, your customers retain their
own control. This means two things.
First, you're gonna have happier customers
that can take control of their own AWS
environment. And second, you're also
going to be able to spend less time
configuring settings on behalf of the
customer just because they don't have
the right management account level access
in order to set up their own
organizations. It'll make it easier for you to
onboard customers, close deals,
and grow those customers.
And AWS will continue supporting
mutual growth across the ecosystem
as we continue on into 2026.
We'll continue to invest
in these new billing capabilities to make
sure that there's no trade-off and
customers ever experience based on
their decision to procure
through a channel partner.
This truly represents the future of channel
partner billing
built on a single platform of
trust
and shared success.
To get started with billing transfer, you can
start today.
Billing transfer is officially generally available
as well as the new Partner Central channel
management experience.
You can access it through AWS
Partner Central.
AWS Partner Central is now available through the
AWS console as well, so you can
access this entire experience through the console
or in your existing AWS Partner
Central experience.
From there you can start adding customers
and initiate billing relationships
to ask your customers to transfer billing
to you while they retain control of their own
organization. Here you'll find
our technical guides,
um, which will help you understand how you
can add new customers to
billing transfer and how you can migrate
some of your existing customers who have root
access conflict
into billing transfers so that they're able to
take back
control of their organizations.
And with that I'd like to say thank you for
joining us,
um, and let me know if you have
any questions we're happy to help,
uh, and always we'll support you in your
journey either as an end customer of
a channel partner or a partner yourself.
Thank you.